pour moi comme jeune franco manitobain
c'était extrêmement important qu'on
reconnaisse qui j'étais raymond hébert
j'avais 17 ans en 1969 lorsque le poste
de commissaire aux langues officielles
qu'il occupe aujourd'hui a été créé avec
l'adoption de la nouvelle loi
qu'est ce qu'on devrait faire c'est
invalidé du bilingue mais parce que
c'était pas du tout accepté à 1969
c'était difficile c'était dur marc
lalonde était chef de cabinet de pierre
elliott trudeau au moment de l'adoption
de cette loi il y avait beaucoup
d'insatisfaction dans la population
francophone y en a pour qui c'était pas
important surtout quelques députés de
l'ouest de profondes divisions
symptomatique de l'époque dans les
années 60 le québec est en pleine
révolution tranquille le mouvement
national en ébullition en mars la
poussée nationaliste et séparatiste a
pris une tournure tragique avec
l'activité du front de libération du
québec
les premières bandes du flq explose
pour répondre à cette crise le premier
ministre lester b pearson créé la
commission sur le bilinguisme et le
biculturalisme la commission n'aura
droit de downton abbey eu pour mandat de
chercher à proposer des solutions pour
permettre que le canada effectivement
que les deux communautés francophones et
anglophones puissent se retrouver donc
une des recommandations qui avait été
fait par la commission
c'était l'adoption justement de la loi
sur les langues officielles nous voulons
respecter la langue des deux principales
communautés linguistiques du pays
si pour les communautés francophones en
situation minoritaire c'était le début
d'une reconnaissance au québec cette loi
était perçu par certains comme une façon
de neutraliser le nationalisme
linguistique
le fait de faire une loi ou ce sont les
individus qui ont des droits et non pas
des collectivités toutes façons de drake
ont tourné leur donnant une cinquante
ans plus tard les combats linguistique
se poursuivre l'application de la loi
demeure épineuse
il est grand temps de la moderniser
selon plusieurs notamment en revoyant
les pouvoirs de son chien de garde le
commissaire le commissaire a beaucoup de
pouvoirs d'enquêté mais pas beaucoup de
pouvoir
pour la mise en oeuvre des
recommandations un engagement du
gouvernement trudeau le fils à l'aube de
la campagne électorale issigeac oudry
chardenoux radio canada
mon frère